this is the season with a lot of sleeper
hits a lot of new anime that i didn't
expect much from coming in only to find
myself pleasantly surprised with what we
ended up with i'm here to give you what
i think are the best new anime that this
summer 2022 season has to offer by the
way i'm not going to be including
sequels because i'm here to showcase
some things that you might want to pick
up black summoner is the title i'll be
starting my list with
time for an isakai this early black
summoner isn't a strong contender for
the number one best anime of the season
but that doesn't mean it can't be
someone's cup of tea and so far i've
appreciated the ride and watching kelvin
bring his blood knight tendencies into
his new life having a battle-hungry
protagonist does seem to be a breath of
fresh air i mean it's been a while since
we've had one of these people who just
basks in the moment and just gives it
his all it's not as much a different
take on an issachai but it certainly
doesn't feel as trite as the genre's
reputation might make you think however
the show can use some work in raising
stakes for giving us more hype moment
it's been a serviceable isakai so far
but with a little more improvement it
could be even better
next in line is engage kiss
engage kiss has been a show that's
really intrigued me coming into the
season being an original anime there's
not a lot of source to draw from and the
premise alone gives it the reputation of
being a hybrid rom-com with some
slapstick and action thrown in after the
first few episodes i think that my
expectations were met and while this
won't be anywhere close to being the
anime of the season i did actually find
myself entertained the show isn't just
decent though if we look at it it's a
mishmash of different genres and tropes
but when it comes to the production
quality engage kiss really shines the
character designs are very attractive
and you can easily get a feel of the
personalities that they're supposed to
represent plus the animation is nothing
short of spectacular however it doesn't
bring too much new stuff to the table
but in areas that my non-reviewer self
really cares about like you know pretty
characters the tropes i've always had
fun with and great art it's one that i
really love
next up we have futo pi
when the season started i wasn't so sure
what to make of this one the show itself
does seem enjoyable but i just wondered
how carmen ryder would translate into
the full-blown anime format it just
seems to be a match made in heaven but
with this being one of the few such
endeavors you never know overall i will
say that it is thrilling yet it never
delves too much into the serious moments
and it does do a good job in forming an
interplay between that and the
light-hearted moment it's also got some
smooth animation that we'll never see in
live action so that's a plus too love
yourself some action with a dash of
mystery and supernatural then futo pi
might be your jam for this season as a
standalone detective show it's enjoyable
and there's a lot to keep you engaged
both the actual story and the fighting
as expected of his tokutatsu roots
parallel world pharmacy is next
[Music]
there's nothing that inspires too much
confidence parallel world pharmacy set
up with the rest of its reincarnation
brethren note that i didn't say
different because to its credit the way
the story's set up is quite fresh it
gives off that kingdom-building vibe
where a doctor gets to have a second go
at his real-world frustrations in
another world while simultaneously
trying to fix the state of the fantasy
world and its culture all in all
parallel world fantasy excels in
capturing that chill vibe whereas a lot
of izakaya are about adventures and
quests to save the world parallel world
pharmacy relishes in the easy going
atmosphere that it has sure it's not
completely slice of life with a few
complications like say the first
princess connect season they're still
very chill while giving us some more
subtle digs at the wrongs of society the
overall positive atmosphere exuded by
the art and the character designs served
to support that purpose and i think that
this is a nice change of pace from the
usual it's a guide that we've been
seeing
let's move on to a remake now it's ruby
ice queendom
ruby has a storied history in my book
well i won't call it a pop culture
phenomenon that exploded into the
mainstream it still flows in and out of
public consciousness and with this
decently sized fan base it didn't come
as a surprise that we'd eventually get
an actual anime ruby as for how well ice
queendom holds i think it's done a
pretty good job all things considered i
won't say the ice queendom is the remake
the ruby fans had hoped for because
actually in some ways it's worse than
the original material especially with
the rushing albeit in a way that didn't
really detract from it if we're just
taking personal opinions from someone
who's consumed a lot of light novel
adaptations it was never going to be a
fully faithful retelling a one-on-one
rendition of the beloved series but with
updated art but the things that it does
do well like recreating characters and
moments in anime style there is some
good to see the point where it branches
off from the mainline story did really
actually get me intrigued i'm looking
forward to the future developments that
the team has in store what's the
original to help yourself enjoy the show
better though as a standalone it is
still a decent watch and if ice
queendom's purpose is to be a commercial
to get people to check out the original
ruby i'd say it's a good way to go at it
you know these summer shows are awesome
and all but do you know the real pain of
not being able to watch them through
guilt-free legal means yeah i mean i
sure do and that's why i'm here to
introduce today's sponsor expressvpn you
know with cyber security becoming a
bigger concern by the day with streaming
services trying to one-up each other
with region locks imagine trying to
watch something like parallel world
pharmacy one of the best ongoing shows
by the way at the moment but having zero
access to it it's just a pain to deal
with isn't it but thankfully we have
expressvpn here to help you tap into the
supposed potential of the internet to
help you cross boundaries like never
before do you know in a lot of asian
countries you can watch anime episodes
on youtube legally through a channel
called muse asia just open expressvpn
and select the indian server and now you
can watch dozens of anime on youtube
itself for free it's easy right
providing maximum security and unmatched
efficiency expressvpn's your answer to
defeat all those online browsing worlds
and i can help you get started too you
can click the link in the description
box or go to www.expressvpn.com
vinnie tube to get three months of
service for free it's a deal that's just
too good to pass up try expressvpn today
for a faster safer and more enjoyable
surfing experience my stepmom's daughter
is my ex is next on the list
[Music]
now this is a show that i was very
excited for coming into the season it's
no secret right that besides action
filled shonen series a personal love of
mine is the rom-com genre with a lot of
misunderstandings awkward moments and
fan service moments here and there in
this season my stepmom's daughter
scratches that itch and i came out
getting way more than i bargained for i
feel that this is the polarizing new
anime of this season however beneath all
of that is what i feel is a genuinely
charming story while the characters are
nothing to write home about critically
speaking it's their dynamic that's made
them so endearing and that's doubly true
with our main pair and the numerous
mishaps that they experienced through
the show's run it's cute but in a
different way the ayamu from earlier was
still it doesn't make it any less fun to
watch if you're up for a slightly
different brand of rom-com
going on
let's move on to yakuza guide to
babysitting
[Music]
i gotta say it's been a good year for
family anime we just had spy family take
the world by storm and feeding off that
momentum is yakuza guide to babysitting
this is a show that i didn't expect to
feel so good about entering the season
but it actually ended up being one of
the more enjoyable ones a lot of that is
due to how fun it is seeing the
characters in action the premise already
opened a lot of possibilities for
mindless fun but i instead got a very
heartwarming and wholesome tale out of
it i was prepared for dumb fun and
craziness like spy family and like the
latter i've got a decent dose of gut
punches but in a good way it's not the
most unique show given that we're in
2022 but it doesn't have to be that way
it's great to have anime be something
you watch when you just want to lose
yourself in sweet moments bright art and
an overall positive atmosphere to
distract yourself from the rest of the
world in that category this show
definitely passes with flying colors
opening our last three is call of the
night
[Music]
coming into the season call of the night
is the new anime that people have been
hyped for it takes the once popular
vampire genre and shines it in a new
light in a different genre that doesn't
involve dark romance full of
contrivances and drama gory and over the
top fights or just plain old battle
shonen in worlds not too different from
our own call of the night instead goes
down the romance route but one that's
just full of fan service though it's not
that call of the night is an edgy fest
or anything of that sort and while the
characters take a while to like they
serve their purpose well as far as
adding flavour to the whirlwind of
romance and given all of that i'd
concede that call of duty isn't a show
for everyone as mentioned yes the fan
service is there and it does delve into
some implications that people might find
unfortunate however for people who don't
care about those like me what awaits is
an engaging story that happens to fit
some relatable themes into it all while
maintaining a cozy feel befitting the
calm nights we'd often see in peaceful
days i'd say
next sport goes to uncle from another
world
following the success of your boy kong
ming we've got yet another fish out of
water anime and this one manages to be
just as if not more fun uncle from
another world swaps out the historical
for the isekai and while the tags
negative connotations may actually put
people off at first a quick look at the
first episode will tell you that this is
nothing near a generic isakai if it's
even one at all actually uncle from
another world's success relies on its
fourth wall breaking and metacommentary
which does create comedy that caters to
a certain niche making the show a kind
of love it or hate it deal when it works
it works and for me it does work i
particularly love the metacometry and
it's got a lot of wacky things like the
reaction faces to further drive home the
fact that yes you're not supposed to
take this show seriously it is weird it
is wild and unhinged and it's something
you often watch with your brains off and
just sitting back for the ride for those
who are part of its target audience the
show works spectacularly and is one of
the biggest recommendations i could give
you this season
[Music]
the final anime on the list is licorice
recoil
little girls being put in the front
lines of some special ops isn't a new
premise well i won't say that shows like
princess principal released the spice or
arya the scarlet ammo took the world by
storm the latest addition to that
sub-genre liquorice recoil definitely
has and it's by far the biggest surprise
of the season and if not it's probably
second or something like that so how
does this show managed to rise far
higher in popularity than its peers
right now well admittedly it's a show
that has an average plot with some
interesting bits but let's not kid
ourselves here the true elements
carrying the show are the characters and
the action they are excellent even
better than the other peers in a genre
and to be honest i'm not sure how much
of a hot take that is the fight
choreography and how the characters play
off each other all do their share of
heavy lifting pushing the show to the
top of the popularity charts this season
overall this is a show that completely
caught me off guard when it comes to
reception and entertainment value i
found myself thoroughly having a blast
watching each of the episodes and while
i think that the storytelling and
backdrop on the world of characters like
chisato show a chance with some added
potential i don't even think that
licorice recall needs it that badly not
now at least when it manages to be so
satisfyingly entertaining every week
well how about sharing your rankings for
this season's new anime out there in the
comments section it's really fun being
able to read your comments it's even
more fun to be able to connect through
social media which is why i'll be
putting up links to the channel's
discord and social media channels feel
free to drop in say hi and just have a
nice time chatting once again thanks for
watching don't forget to like and
subscribe and i'll see you next time